firefighters in las vegas are getting  new mattresses today walker furniture  and las vegas fire and rescue continuing  their project firehouse rested and ready  program it provides new mattresses and  foundations to fire stations they've  delivered 12 new mattresses to station  41 today  we're one of the fewer fire departments  in the country that  are really working from beginning to end  on all calls  and these men and women need  great sleep and having a new mattress a  mattress that  fits and contours to their body and  that's ergonomic is essential to them  being rested  their goal is to replace the 152  mattresses at the 15 fire stations in  the area